bonjour ici des monts de marteau à radio
canada international aujourd'hui dans
notre dossier immigration on se penche
sur la perception de l'immigration par
des gens de premières nations
notre collègue et invités partenaires
mélissa mollen bonjour on se disait bien
sûr tout est ok le bonjour dans nombre
de nation autochtone un peu partout
c'est la manière un peu de rangement il
ya plusieurs façons il coache désole
benaki ckoi et cool oui exact mais tu
peux exécuter ou précuits coincé vries
comme un petit bonjour cars immigration
et première nation c'est comme si on
sont elles la période au centre de la
rive ajout de l'arrivée des des
européens
bon les nations existent les premières
nations sayen période de reconnaissance
qui est en train d'émerger
mais il ya aussi une très forte
immigration de plus en plus d'immigrants
qu'un alors pourquoi d'un quart de
million par année 40 milles sur le
québec est ce qu une perception
différente pense de toi qui vit dans les
deux communautés et blanches et
autochtone de la perception de
l'immigration
oui ben d'ailleurs je n'aime pas
beaucoup de ces le terme immigrants
j'aime parce que j'ai l'impression que
ce terme là et vient maintenant avec une
connotation très négative
puis c'est souvent ces mêmes validé
soins comme c'est l'autre c'est
l'envahisseur c'est celui qui viennent
ou volé moi je préfère le terme migrants
quelqu'un qui bouge parce que même nous
les peuples autochtones on était des
décès dans des semis sédentaires et
nomades on se déplaçait sur le
territoire selon nos besoins si les
ressources étaient plus là il fallait
qu'on se déplace donc on était souvent
obligés d'aller vers d'autres
territoires même des fois de partager
des territoires avec d'autres nations
ça faisait partie d'une réalité d'une
communication qui devait se créer entre
les nations
aujourd'hui c'est comme s'il y avait un
peuple qui était plus valides et qu'un
autre et tous ceux qui eux sont à la
recherche d'une ressource et cette
ressource a peut être même juste le
désir de ne pas mourir dans une guerre
de pauvres des injustices ou de titres
juste de pouvoir accéder à une bonne
manière de vivre pour ses enfants pour
des futurs un petit enfant ça devient
quasiment comme si on venait volet de
quoi alors que je pense que n'importe
quel être humain
dans ma conception en moyenne en
conception qui vit à la tradition ont le
droit d'exister
là où ses pieds se trouve le droit de
vivre de partager les ressources l'eau
la nourriture mais il est quand même une
responsabilité qui est celle de
respecter ceux qui ont la responsabilité
du territoire parce qu'on parle pas de
possession de territoires
la relation avec le sol est complètement
différent oui car quand les européens
sont arrivés n'est pas le faisais ça
c'est notre territoire c'est à nous des
chefs qui ont ri viande bien parti avait
pas posséder le territoire se partager
est ce qu'ils ont
les licences sur ce territoire là depuis
avant les avants les nouveaux milieux là
justement ont la responsabilité de
s'assurer que les ressources sont
suffisantes partage que respect aussi
des cycles pour s'assurer que ce soit
une pérennité la survie humaine
quand quelqu'un arrive et il demande à
ta mission pouvoir partager le
territoire et des fois quand les
ressources étaient pas assez bonnes vous
avez malheureusement non ça marche pas
mais on pourrait essayer de chasser
enfants ont pour essayer de trouver les
ressources et caïn réussissez à voir la
chasse il partageait avec l'eau donc il
y avait une entraide qui devenait était
humaine plus que liés aux nations
aujourd'hui c'est même pas une question
de survie de base c'est juste une
question de deux pères qui sont créées
donc moi quand je suis l'idée de
nouveaux arrivants je suis cette idée
traditionnel de tous les êtres humains
qui sont bonnes volontés qui viennent
pour les mêmes choses que moi je
voudrais avoir si j'étais dans la misère
on peut vivre avec on peut travailler
ensemble mais malheureusement à
l'immigration
c'est maintenant utiliser plus comme un
bateau pour faire peur aux gens
alors que on voit bien que à part pour
les peuples autochtones qui ça fait des
dizaines de milliers d'années qu'on est
ici pour mettre le nom d'elie de
l'émigration ou même des états unis ont
longtemps eu cette belle image de
l'immigrant les nouveaux pauvres ou
laissés pour compte
la statue de liberté qu'est le grand
symbole et maintenant la france et les
gens temps des histoires que un citoyen
anglais né en angleterre pour même pas
avec une double citoyenneté se fait
bloquer
à l'aéroport pour pouvoir rentrer au
cesi juste parce qu'il n'ait pas l'air
bien il ya un délit de faciès à ouvrir
une session
mais dans la perception non autochtone
il arrive parfois que ayant un discours
pour faire peur aux gens m'ont dit de
l'immigration qui dit bon ce sont nos
valeurs nos cultures qui sont donc
diluer
qu'en est il de la perception méridien
par rapport à cet aspect là avec la
présence de l'immigrant du nouvel
arrivant
c'est certain que le nouvel le nouvel
arrivant et pau celui qui va avoir ou
kyo diluer notre culture sont venues des
politiques canadiennes qui ont fait ce
travail là
intentionnellement détruit valeur la
culture l'identité même les droits
territoriaux
ce qui est malheureux par exemple c'est
justement ce genre de politique là on
crée parfois chez des premières nations
et les peuples autochtones
une crainte de l'autre parce que disent
ils nous ont fait ce qu'est ce qui nous
dit pas que n'importe qui pour nous le
faire mais il y aussi par exemple une
relation qui s'est construite en deux
peuples qui des fois vivre des
discriminations 1
depuis l'arrivée des européens et
l'autre après lui son arrivée ça permet
pas de créer des relations on a des
communautés où quelqu'un issu dé souche
africaine des souches européen mais
mélangé avec des idées ou des attikameks
des algonquins des mois et ça crée un
nouvel apport dans la communauté faut
pas oublier que les premières nations
ont adopté d'aider d'autres nations avec
nous on adore intelligent avec nous
mêmes aux états unis s'il faut il
appelle les black angels c'est les
enfants sont issus des relations qu'ont
été créés en plaisir américaine des
attaques tonnes des états unis et les
premiers esclaves en fuite
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'esclaves ont fait
en fait se sont dirigés vers les
communautés autochtones pour pouvoir
survivre et éviter d'être pris en
esclavage donc il y avait une adoption
il y avait une intégration accrue mais
aussi l'adoption des traditions nous
encore les européens sont arrivés il y
avait des traditions qu'on a beaucoup
adopté comme le métal le chaudron
l'épinglé dessus des choses qui étaient
de petits étaient bonnes et même on a
adapté des français des anglais dans nos
nations et encore aujourd'hui on voit
qu'on mélange c'est impossible d'avoir
peur de l'autre à ce point là tout le
temps c'est certain que certains
individus vont pousser vers ce message
de fo se séparer fausses photos il faut
garder les sangs purs
mais c'est pas seuls déchaîné l'idée
c'était d'être ensemble de se mélanger
de pouvoir vivre ensemble et ça crée une
nouvelle culture
aujourd'hui le peuple autochtone est ce
qu'il est parce qu'il a pris ce qui
était bon pour lui d autres nations mais
a conservé une
ce qui était le meilleur de sa culture à
lui à leur échelle et c'est pour ça
aussi que chaque nation au canada
autochtone est pas la même genre je suis
pas du tout pareil comme un mois et moi
qui ai pas du tout comme une limite ou
comme un sioux commence haute-voix la
raison mais on se reconnaît comme peuple
autochtone et on se respecte en tant que
tel alors je pense que c'est possible de
le faire avec
l'entièreté des nations qui existent sur
la planète mais toujours dans un respect
des équilibres et de dévalorisation de
l'autre et pas d'une diminution de ce
que l'autre vos culturellement un beau
message sociaux
melissa maulin semestre mais merci
beaucoup merci à vous